there's biological reasons for the
reasons we feel the way we feel if a guy
can get other girls it's a form of
pre-selection
so so that signals to us he could take
care of those women therefore he can
take care of me too so that's why it's
attractive to us a man that's been with
more women on the other hand men value
purity because their biological
imperative was they don't want to put
resources into a kid that's not theirs
and so that's why they value a lower
body count because if they don't want to
they want to make sure that kid is
theirs and then if you want to talk
about body count so a woman that's only
had that's a virgin when she gets
married she has an eighty percent chance
of a happy marriage within ten years and
she's like if she's if she's if she's
okay again we're talking about
the stats so this 80 chance of a happy
marriage in 10 years if you slept with
more than five people which i think most
men pray for nowadays
their chance of a happy marriage is 25
so it goes from 80 to 25 percent so and
it keeps dropping lower and lower